Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie.
This is going to be my Sherlock episode two
video.
Just careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the episode yet big major reveals there is
a new round of the Sherlock giveaway is just
a $20 Amazon gift card.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video winners
usually announced at the end so be sure to
click that bell to enable alerts so you don't
miss anything so big reveals.
There's something about the number three people
just stop looking.
So we learned about the third sibling with
a teaser with you know may be there might
be 1/4 because people stop looking after three
we just met the third in her name is you rose
not share inferred which is on Mycroft's pad.
So the actual episode title itself the line
detective is an Easter egg for the adventure
of the dying detective which is a culvert
tinsmith story so the basic plot of how Sherlock
tries to trick Cole written into getting a
confession out of them is basically lifted
right out of that original home story in the
book version.
Sherlock just suspects him of his nephews
murder instead of being like an outright serial
killer, but the way the book describes him
just is so perfect the way Toby Jones looks
just so creepy.
So this is actually how it reads in the book
with a shrill cry of anger a man rose from
a reclining chair beside the fire.
I saw great yellow face coarse-grained and
greasy with heavy double chin and to Solon
menacing gray eyes which glared at me from
under tufted and Sandy browse a high baldhead
had a small velvet smoking Poised upon one
side of its pink her.
The school was of enormous capacity and yet
as I looked down and saw to my amazement that
the figure of the man was small and frail
twisted in the shoulders and the back like
one who had suffered from rickets in his childhood,
so he's essentially describing Gollum from
the Lord of the rings and upstanding member
of the community who seems that this really
impish horrifying figure that just screams
villain like you look at him and you just
know that something's off.
So the cinematography the costume design the
makeup.
Everything looked amazing in this episode
it was so trippy, but you have to remember
that Sherlock was on drugs, so that he could
go to hell is Mary had asked him if for some
reason I missed the post credits scene after
the last episode cited learn about until after
the episode aired, but the guest was is that
she was giving him directions like she wasn't
cursing him.
She was telling them to go to the place that
is hell, so we got the explainer for that
and it was a roundabout way to save Jon Watson
by having him save Sherlock.
So it worked and we finally found out what
was up with Watson texting that mystery female
which surprise surprise was the secret sibling
of Mycroft in Sherlock not to be confused
with Sharon Ford because when she's saying
all the names of her family members she leaves
out Sharon for the lion's case against US
troops city name is a queen which means the
east wind has some city names I you Mycroft
should have attention on even one section
secret and share inferred the theoretical,
third brother the supposed to be even smarter
than Mycroft like Sherlock is smart Mycroft
is even smarter and share inferred is supposed
to be this towering intellect above all of
them was originally the name that Arthur Conan
Doyle was going to name Sherlock.
His main character but then changed it.
The character doesn't literally exist in the
canon of the books.
It was just the theoretical creation to explain
why Sherlock and Mycroft were forced to follow
their parents in their chosen profession and
were able to go off and do the things that
they did during the novels.
So share inferred was something that was added
after the fact to sort of cleanup the logic
of the story is just a little bit, but because
the producers pull from all over Sherlock
Canon and because they have a very special
line everyone stopped looking after three
there's the theory that they will actually
do share inferred on the TV show people kept
thinking that it was going to be Tom Hiddleston.
They interviewed him at the Golden globes
and he's like why do people keep saying that
I'm not doing Sherlock I'm not on that TV
show so the third secret sibling in this episode
euros is probably the person that Mycroft
is referring to when he says the other one
someone who is kept locked in a tower as Jon
Watson jokes, so by the end of the episode.
The way she explains it is that she left Sherlock
a lot of Clues when he's deducing things about
her like she lives in a very small room because
the way the papers folded in the way the sunlight
fell on it, you kinda have to take that with
a grain of salt because like the literal name
of the episode the line detective.
She's lying quite a bit and she was lying
to Sherlock.
So it's hard to know exactly what her Backstory
is, but presumably will find out in the next
episode because of that major cliffhanger
the crazy thing if you missed it.
She says that a mutual friend put her in touch
with Cole written, which gave her based original
note like the actual daughter of culvert and
who Sherlock thought he was meeting with,
so the note itself was authentic but euros
here sounds like she might have been working
with Moriarty because of the miss me.
So even though Sherlock is playing Moriarty's
great game.
His sibling is a part of it.
So you see Heather like twisting this making
this a very tight family affair.
Just heightening the drama that way.
So Sherlock is good have to take someone down
by the end of the series possibly kill someone
again and it sounds like it might end up being
his sister which is all the more tragic, which
is the ovarian keeping with the tone of the
series so the culverts and plot is still ongoing
like he just keeps confessing like you will
totally walk off Scott free his leg during
series 2 where Moriarty was a very happy to
give himself over the place like he wanted
to get caught because he knew he would be
able to get off.
So as culvert and says he has all this money
well he's very tight with the Queen he could
get off Scott free if he wants, so he can't
stop confessing.
Even though Sherlock says that their evidence
is inadmissible.
So the culverts and plot will carry over into
the next episode as well as Sherlock and Mycroft
sisters.
So was all completely WTF I love the way they
use Mary in this episode in Mrs. Hudson was
amazing.
Of course that's my car.
I was married to a drug dealer no you can't
borrow it.
In fact, she actually solves the mystery of
Sherlock or Mycroft she's like look what is
Sherlock do when he can't solve a mystery.
He stabs something he shoots the wall so she
was a complete bad ass in this episode it
was a great way to open it to with that car
chasing which he just gets out and then surprise
surprise Sherlock is in the boot.
So even though was a drug fueled, tour de
force.
There was a lot of humor in the episode.
Let me know in the comments do you actually
think that they're going to reveal share for
is the secret fourth Holmes sibling they'll
be like a crazy WTF everybody stops looking
after three and I almost forgot Irene Adler
is still very much a part of the series.
He even admitted to texting her in moments
of weakness.
He's like were all human Jon when he was trying
to explain that even though Watson was cheating
on his wife by texting he was a human being.
Everyone is human so they finally revealed
when his birthday was no idea if they attend
actually physically bring her on an episode.
I don't know if Laura Pulver the actress was
available, but it would be amazing for the
fans, especially if the neck in a do another
season of Sherlock for a while.
They have really announce what their plans
are.
After this season so we can talk about that
when I post my finale video but it would be
a lot of fun.
Speaking of which, congratulations to this
week's giveaway winner Stephen Montes you
and a $20 Amazon gift card just be sure to
private message me on the back and my channel
so I can get your contact details is a new
round that started in this video so.
Just announce the winner the next time I post
to Sherlock video, so new episode posting
next week.
Who knows maybe we'll surprise us and they'll
be like a secret fourth episode but I'm not
expecting that what you guys wait for that
to post you can click here for my Sherlock
episode one video and you can click here for
all the other crazy stuff is coming up because
need to get really excited about that you
so much watching I'll see you guys in the
next video!